how's it going guys and don't worry I'm
not changing the background or anything
it's just not read right now because
this this isn't a movie review this is
more of a hey here's something cool for
you guys video so I made a video that I
just kind of threw together I saw the
trailer - something I'm not going to
tell you what yet and I thought to
myself I think that would go well with
this music which I'm also not going to
tell you yet so I sit down cut this
together and sure enough at least in my
opinion I think it goes well together
it's kind of funny but it goes well
together now we don't have the video on
this page right here because if I put it
on this page YouTube will just be like I
just don't want to deal with that [ __ ]
so I put a link below to where you can
find a go check it out couple things you
need to remember when watching this
video one I am a Star Wars fan I'm a
huge Star Wars fan original trilogy that
[ __ ] is solid and two I am actually a
straight man funny I have to give that
disclaimer before you watch this video
but I think you'll like it because if
you're subscribed to me you're probably
about as crazy Xion I think and you love
you some Star Wars videos so again the
links below go check it out I also put
said video that I made as a video
response to this video so it's right
below also either way the videos below
after you see it come back here and
comment on this page cuz I'm not gonna
check the other page really I hope you
enjoy it I don't know why I did this